What's up everybody!
We are Pongfinity and welcome to another episode of Challenge Pongfinity.
This is the series where YOU challenge US with your craziest ideas related to table tennis.
If your idea gets picked, we'll feature it and give it a shoutout.
So make sure to leave your comments in the comments below!
So our good friend Benedek Olah has challenged us to the around the bottle challenge
Where you have to serve around the bottle placed on the other side of the table.
Jack Green wants us to make a behind the back around the net shot from a through the legs around the net shot.
Shouldn't be hard. Let's do it!
Sebastian Edvardsson wants us to play with our wrong hand and do around the net shots.
So let's see who can do the most!
Devendra Kumar Jain wants us to play with two rackets.
Demirzhan Sabrii suggests, we should play with a hairdryer.
The next challenge is down to you guys.
Cody Zet wants us to get 3000 likes in this video.
So make sure you give this video a like
Thanks for watching guys
If you're new to the channel subscribe here
And check out our other videos here.
Also, if you don't have your own Pongfinity t-shirts yet, go to the link below.